on va se retrouver pour cette nouvelle
année nous bien au chaud avec vous du
lundi au vendredi dans la bibliothèque
de vous êtes formidable et à l'heure où
l'on surveille un petit peu la
température extérieure et surtout la
consommation d'énergie j'en ai connu une
qui va nous emmener en voyage dans le
Grand Nord c'est ce que vous nous disiez
en débutant cette émission histoire de
bien nous énerver bref vous nous emmener
au grand air pourquoi donc dites-moi
Tiphaine
et passionnants comme celui-ci qui
s'appelle justement Grand Nord alors
c'est un petit peu pour les plus grand
quand c'est plutôt à partir de 7-8 ans
mais quand on fait la lecture vous savez
ça peut toujours les intéresser alors ce
livre là et bien c'est un livre de Jess
gouzen est marié thème Berg et ça nous
présente et bien 35 animaux polaires
alors c'est assez original puisque les
animaux et bien se présentent par
eux-mêmes à la première personne il nous
disent qu'elles sont leurs relations
familiales leur prédateurs ce qu'ils
aiment dans la vie alors ça permet aux
enfants très bien de s'identifier un peu
plus à ces animaux qui sont très
lointains et vous le voyez il y a des
gravures sur linoléum qui sont très très
jolies qui font un peu penser à de l'art
inuit alors on croise et bien des
animaux très connus comme le renne le
phoque ou bien le lièvre mais aussi des
animaux méconnus comme le Mergule nain
que je ne connaissais pas du tout
personnellement et qui ressemble un
petit peu à un manchot alors c'est
publié aux éditions Rue du Monde et
c'est presque autant un livre
documentaire qu'un livre d'art je vous
le conseille j'ai appris plein de choses
par exemple savez-vous Pascal que le
phoque annelé trompe l'ours polaire en
faisant des bulles dans l'eau
même le monde animé
ça va pas du tout puisqu'on est dans les
questions j'ai une maman aussi sur ce
plateau vous avez une maman
vous êtes pendant une maman de deux
enfants si je me trompe pas c'est
Simonian à elle ils ont 7 et 12 ans j'ai
bien entendu ce que disait Tiphaine 7
ans on est pile dans la cible là en plus
très intéressé par les animaux donc
effectivement
ça peut plaire il y a un animal non j'ai
pas compris le nom là vous m'avez dit
vous-même ne pas le connaître c'était
quoi cet animal là bizarre
c'est un oiseau qui ressemble au manchot
mais comme c'est un oiseau et bien il
vole ok je vois parfait on va se poser
en douceur
on va se dire que pour bien connaître un
endroit rien de tel que de s'y rendre en
enfance des portes ouvertes là mais
cette fois cap sur le sud et
l'Antarctique avec un livre on va dire
très original c'est moins qu'on puisse
dire oui ça s'appelle expédition
Antarctique et il y a tout dedans pour
pouvoir s'y rendre parce qu'elle sait
pas si c'est vos prochains vos
prochaines vacances mais Tanya medveda
et Maria vices niskaïa ont tout mis
dedans puisqu'on suit Tom un aventurier
qui prépare son voyage alors il nous dit
tout ce qu'il faut emporter il nous
explique qui y est déjà allé les
premiers aventuriers par exemple et puis
le fonctionnement de la station météo
qui s'y trouve et qui permet de
accueillir des données scientifiques
très importantes alors personnellement
j'ai appris énormément de choses qui
pourraient vous intéresser par exemple
comment construire un igloo c'est utile
une fois sur place comment se forme un
iceberg et puis pourquoi les batteries
de téléphone se déchent plus vite quand
il fait froid mais vous le voyez c'est
un livre très très original puisqu'il a
une forme très particulière quand il
s'ouvre et bien il peut prendre une
forme ronde alors d'habitude on le lit
en demi-cercle comme cela vous le voyez
mais on peut l'ouvrir et ça forme alors
un planisphère c'est très intéressant
c'est les éditions Rue du Monde qui font
ça également et vraiment c'est
passionnant c'est très drôle ça permet à
toutes les petites mains de le lire et
en même temps c'est très documenté
puisque c'est une professeure diplômée
de Harvard qui l'a écrit parfait si j'en
crois ma vue bio ionique il y avait
marqué à partir de 8 ans c'est ça oui
c'est ça c'est plutôt à partir de 8 ans
et c'est sans limite d'âge puisque c'est
passionnant parfait
vous avez aussi un roman alors on va
grimper un petit peu ça va faire plaisir
à notre maman qui est là on est plutôt
dans dans les collégiens donc 12 ans on
est pile dedans là c'est quoi donc et
bien ça s'appelle les enfants de Noé de
Jean Joubert et c'est une réédition en
poche d'un roman assez ancien qui date
des années 80 et qui imaginait un futur
en 2036 avec du dérèglement climatique
donc on est plein dedans c'est
totalement d'actualité et c'est la
famille de Simon qui habite dans les
Alpes et qui se retrouve piégé par des
chutes de neige interminables alors il
va falloir et bien apprendre à
s'organiser à quatre privés
d'électricité privée de radio coupé du
monde c'est un roman très intéressant
pour savoir et bien comment on trouve
les ressources
psychiques pour s'organiser les
ressources aussi et bien tout simplement
pour se nourrir vraiment je vous le
conseille c'est à la fois philosophique
à la fois drôle et figurez-vous qu'on
trouve les ressources et bien dans les
livres et dans la fantaisie donc je vous
le conseille c'est une fable sur la
fragilité de la nature et l'importance
de la famille pour commencer l'année je
pense que c'est utile et ben parfait la
sélection livre de notre région est
d'ailleurs à retrouver aussi sur le net
et les réseaux sociaux pensez-y Tifenn